[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - OZARK HENRY, "WE CAN BE
HEROES"]
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Please help me
welcome to the stage artist
and composer Ozark Henry
and acclaimed mixing and
audio engineer Ronald Prent.
Thank you much for
joining us today.
Thank you so much
for being here.
RONALD PRENT: Alright, welcome.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So it was very cool
for me to be able to sit here
and look out at the faces,
and see the people really
engaging with that experience.
If you could describe
for us what exactly
was that they just sat through?
OZARK HENRY: Well,
especially for the people
in the middle, because
they are the ones who
are sitting within our set up.
They've experienced immersive
sound, immersive meaning
generating a 3D image
that blurs the lines
between the digital
and physical.
Or to say it in a
simpler way, when
I'm performing
with an orchestra,
I am always amid the orchestra.
I'm not in front
of the orchestra,
meaning that I'm always
surrounded by sound.
I'm immersed in sound.
And immersive sound gives
you that same experience
in recorded music.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Do
you agree with that?
Is there more to it?
RONALD PRENT: Most certainly.
No, it is a new way of having
the listener experience
the creative process
of an artist that
wants to communicate his
music in a different way.
And in stereo, it's fine,
and on an iPod, it's fine.
On headphones, it's fine.
But this, you actually
put inside the music
that the guy
created, or the girl,
and you live the
emotional experience,
which is so much
bigger and so much more
involved with yourself than
just listening to two speakers.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So you
said something very interesting
that I'm going to
key off of, which
is to bring the listener
along with the process.
This particular audio sample
that everyone just heard
comes off of your
album, "Paramount."
OZARK HENRY: Yes.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Which is the
chicken and the egg question.
Which came first?
The idea for the album?
You were involved with the
National Orchestra of Belgium,
via invitation.
How did that cascade into
creating all of this?
OZARK HENRY: Well,
the thing is that I
was invited by the National
Orchestra of Belgium
to curate my work using their
fantastic 90 piece orchestra.
And knowing that my dad
is a classical composer,
that's the music and the sound
that I was brought up with.
For me, it was an opportunity
to really full circle.
I wanted to explore and
to score every color,
every dynamic I could get
from such a big orchestra.
And of course,
being a producer, I
wanted to record,
record it in a way that
hasn't been done
before, not thinking
at that time about
immersive sound,
because I didn't
even know it existed.
But I wanted to have
a really big canvas,
because that is very important
to put a 90 piece orchestra.
And I wanted to do
something about the space.
I wanted to share that
special emotion you have
when being immersed
by that big sound
when performing with them.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So in
trying to tackle that problem,
somewhere along the
lines, you began
to work with the Auro-3D chaps?
OZARK HENRY: Well,
it was step by step.
The first thing I had
to question myself
is, what is the canvas?
I have some footage too.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah, a
very good way to explain this.
OZARK HENRY: A
good way to explain
this is, what is a canvas,
and asking yourself,
does size matter in music?
This is Pablo
Picasso's "Guernica,"
a painting he made
in 1937 expressing
the horror he witnessed
in events that
would lead up to World War II.
People who have had
the opportunity to see
this in real life, it's huge.
It's 3 and 1/2 meters high.
It's almost 8 meters
wide, so it wouldn't even
never fit in this room.
Why is it so big?
Because of what the
content is saying to you.
it says, there's a war coming.
It's a monster, and
it's unstoppable.
I think with music
being an art form,
as painting is an
art form, one has
to always question
what canvas will
I use when starting
a certain work?
I was sure that working with
a 90 piece orchestra having
the richest instrument
possible in color and dynamic,
I needed to have a
really big canvas.
Luckily, I have a big
canvas, the canvas
that I normally work in.
And that is my canvas.
The white circle
represents my canvas.
The size of the
circle represents
the quality of my canvas.
And within that canvas, I have
placed a 90 piece orchestra.
The size of the pictogram
just represents the quality,
the dynamic, the direction,
everything such a big orchestra
has to offer.
So from my research,
I did understand
that the good thing is that
my canvas is big enough.
But I know that
this is not going
to help me to feel that special
thing, being immersed by sound.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It's like
you can watch a high definition
film, but you're still on
this side of the screen.
OZARK HENRY: Yes, you're
always in front of it.
You're not in the music.
And of course, knowing
Ronald, and knowing
that he's the expert in surround
music mixing, engineering,
recording--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: How
early in the process
did you become involved
in the project?
RONALD PRENT: Very early.
I mean, the idea got settled,
and I wanted to do it.
And Piet called me up.
Pietr [? Robert ?] came
to visit us, and he said,
I'm going to do this.
And he told me what
he just told you guys.
And I said, oh,
that's a big canvas,
but there's a new
technology called Auro-3D
that uses 9 or 10 speakers.
You can choose
which configuration.
Which will allow us to
actually represent your canvas
in a three dimensional
world, and put you
inside or among the
orchestra, and therefore
give the listener a completely
different experience
of your musical ideas.
And from that moment
on, he said, OK.
I want to do this.
So we did the whole
process of the recording,
the mixing, the producing.
Everything was done
with this in mind.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Cool.
Cool.
Even to the point of how
much consideration do
you have to put where
you're placing a microphone,
the orientation of that.
I know we were talking before
about the easy trap of, oh,
I'll just take a
flute and put it over
here, and take a clarinet
and put it over there.
But that doesn't really
serve the purpose.
RONALD PRENT: It doesn't
serve the purpose, no.
You want you want to put
the people in a space,
whether it's virtual
or real doesn't matter.
You want to put them in
a space to experience
the emotional content of
the music more than just
with headphones or two speakers.
And the orchestra is miked in a
traditional way with the Decca
Tree in a very classical way.
Then it's miked in
a second way, which
is more pointed to the
instruments, more pop like.
And it's done in a
three dimensional way,
so there's three
different stages
in which I've recorded
it parallel when
they did live performances.
But you also look where do
you record your orchestra?
Do you do it in the concert
hall, in the studio?
We ended up doing it
in the rehearsal space
of the orchestra.
We went to see the
orchestra before we
started doing our planning.
And that was so powerful.
And I walked around
the orchestra
while they were rehearsing.
And I said to Piet,
I said, I don't
think you have to think
about anything anymore.
We're going to do in this space.
I know it's not meant
to be recorded here.
It's a rehearsal space.
But the power of the orchestra,
you'll never get it in a studio
or in a classical
performance space.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And that
seems to make sense too.
One would think that the
rehearsal space of an orchestra
is designed in a way to
where they are the ones who
are hearing it the best.
RONALD PRENT: Absolutely.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So if you are then
approaching it to
record it in the way
that they would hear it,
it's accomplishing the goals
that you're laying out.
There's a great documentary
that is available
online about the
creation of the album,
and I think we want to
show a snippet of that.
And the documentary is
also in the surround,
so you guys will be
able to experience
a little bit different,
something a little different
than music.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
That's a little insight
into the recording
process and how the way
it was recorded
lead into the mixing
and everything like that.
RONALD PRENT: Yeah.
If you could hear me speak
Dutch, it's my native language.
I don't know if
everybody could read it,
but really quickly,
what I did was
I used three ways of
recording the orchestra.
One is the very classical
way, a classical approach
with Decca Tree in the
front with three microphones
and some support microphones.
And the second
way is really pop,
where each instrument
has its own microphone
so I can control balance.
And then the third way
was I put five microphones
in a square inside
the orchestra.
And those are projected
in the top loudspeakers
here, which gave
me the possibility
to dynamically enhance the
excitement or the arrangement
of the orchestra.
There will be parts in songs
that you play where, basically,
it sounds like a little
chamber orchestra,
although it's a big orchestra.
And it's only
either in the front
or in the bottom
layer of speakers.
And when the orchestra really
gets loud and powerful,
then I add the speakers
as progressive mixing.
In classical, you
wouldn't do that,
or you wouldn't be
allowed to do it,
because it changes the
perspective of the orchestra.
Here, its use is
an extra dimension
to the excitement of the music.
And you can make it small,
and you can make it direct.
You can make it distant
and very romantic,
or you can make it
powerfully loud.
Those were the three
layers that we created.
Didn't know if it was
going to work before.
We recorded it that way because
the room would let us do that.
And then in mixing,
after we did three songs,
we went in the other
studio in a mastering room,
and listened to it
on a bigger system.
And it was really like,
oh, wow, it works.
That's an exciting
moment, because it really
gives such a different
dimension to his music.
OZARK HENRY: This is also
something we have to clear out.
You were working, and
we couldn't check in 9.1
while you were working.
You had to imagine things.
RONALD PRENT: We were
boyscouting at the time.
So you do three processes.
You do stereo, 5.1 and
9.1 at the same time.
So you have to choose
what you listen to.
Because it's not always possible
to listen to all three forms.
It's switchable.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Difficult
to burn the CD and go play it.
RONALD PRENT: Yeah,
you can't do that.
So I choose to work in 5.1 and
not listen to the top speakers.
And then when I
was finished, I'd
take the files into
the other studio,
play it on a real 9.1 set.
Otherwise, it got
too complicated.
Now we're a year
further down the line.
Now there are consoles
developed that can actually
allow you to do that.
So, like technology, it
evolves so fast every year.
Then when we did it, we
couldn't, but now we can.
And it's only a year later.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
You made a touch point
about the emotional experience.
And that made me think
about touching on the fact
that that song that we
heard in the beginning
might have some emotional
connections because it's
the recently the late David
Bowie who created that.
And he works in a
very unique way.
Not anybody can just go along
and cover a David Bowie song.
OZARK HENRY: Which
is a good thing.
I'm a big Bowie fan, so it's
good to have his approval when
you do a cover version.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
How did you approach
David Bowie to say we have this
idea, we want your blessing?
And even to the
point where you were
changing some of the lyrics
and really dismantling
and recombining them somehow.
OZARK HENRY: Well, I have a
little history with Bowie.
When I released my
first album in 1996,
he spoke out openly that he was
a really big fan of that album.
I met him later
on at times that I
wasn't at all successful
with what I was doing.
And he gave me the
confidence and the courage
to keep on doing
what I was doing.
And at the time that I could
do a project like this,
I made that version of "Heroes,"
which I did send to him,
explaining that the way
I edited lyrics changed
the content completely
from what it originally
was talking about.
But it was reflecting
this project specifically
in the sense that a
90 piece orchestra has
40 different nationalities.
We were doing
something that I never
had done before, that was
way bigger than anything
that I've done before.
And that meant that I
had to trust everyone.
And the title of the album
is "Paramount is Harmony.
Respect Each Individual."
I think this was possible
because everybody
was involved in the orchestra.
Engineering, recording,
everybody in the studio,
everybody involved,
the people I work with,
my management-- everybody made
it possible, because we had
the courage to believe in
something and just go for it,
even if we didn't have
any blueprint in knowing
that we would succeed.
And that's where the song
stands for, I think, the way
it's been edited.
And David really liked it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Yeah I was going
to ask if he was
able to hear it.
OZARK HENRY: Yeah, he never
heard it in immersive sound.
He just heard a stereo demo
that I made, unfortunately.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: To
dig a little bit deeper
into the immersive sound
portion, that's the buzz phrase
that we're focusing on.
All of us are
probably old enough
to have gone through
many iterations now
of audio technology,
from tapes to CDs
to the short lived minidisc.
Does this fall into a technology
in the recording and studio
world?
Is it a medium that is going
to be moving to take over?
Is it a playback device?
I mean, you have like high
fidelity in the Pono device,
or FLAC audio files.
Where does this fit in
that large environment?
OZARK HENRY: I think, first
of all, it's a technology.
I mean, it's a medium.
It allows an artist to
have a way bigger canvas,
actually, the canvas
one would always
dream of, to express everything
that is possible with music.
This is, I think, beyond styles.
This is even probably
beyond music.
I think it can express
way more, because it
is the natural way of
listening to things,
the way we experience
sound day to day.
And it gives back
what has been lost,
I think, throughout the
technology and the way
it's been commercialized.
That is, the original work.
And to explain, going
back to the Picasso,
if that were a piece
of music, and you
were to see the original
work, and it would be a song,
and it comes out as a
piece of music today,
and you would be interested
in it, and you would buy it,
you would download it,
or you would stream it.
Then you would have this.
So imagine you're
Pablo Picasso, and you
want to express like the
horror leading to events
that will start a World War.
This is hardly noticeable.
I think it's paying no
respect or no tribute
to what an artist had intended.
And I think an MP3
is a great thing,
because it allows you to
carry music with you on a very
small device.
But is that the purpose of the
one who is making the music?
Is that the purpose
of the artist?
Making something that you can
put in a really small device?
And then, of course,
there's a lot
of people criticizing
the way I presented,
saying but it's music.
You can zoom into it.
But if you zoom into it,
of course, it's deformed.
Going back to what
I said before,
it's all about respecting
the original work.
My interest as an artist
is using technologies
that allow me to offer
an experience which
is way beyond anything
that one can offer now,
but also to share it.
Because I think the biggest
challenge, after all,
was for us not to make this
album using immersive sound,
but the hardest thing is
just to communicate it
and to get it
towards an audience.
Although it's quite easy to
do, because these sound files
may have been big
files some time ago,
but they're not today.
If you can stream a film, then
for sure, you can stream this.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, maybe that's
a bigger question about
technology, to back up.
Because it's clear.
Everyone here probably
has a smartphone
in their pocket with catalogs
upon catalogs of music.
OZARK HENRY: Even I do.
And I think it's great.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
How do you get
around the ubiquity of that,
though, to present them?
How do you first explain
even what they're missing,
and then also translate this
experience to those devices?
I mean, it's easy for us to set
up here with this great speaker
system that these
guys have put in here,
but obviously you can't
walk down the street
with this rig around you.
How do you get
that to the pocket?
OZARK HENRY: Well, the thing is
that for now it's just trying
to communicate what it is.
The only way to do it
is to experience it.
RONALD PRENT: But
there are developments
in the new technology.
For now, we use a pure
audio Blu-ray technology
to be able to play it with
or without video in 9.1.
But sooner, it also will
be possible to stream
this in 9.1 lossless.
And in late spring,
on Android devices
we'll be able to play back
from Android devices in 9.1
and stream it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And we have
some of the representatives
from Auro-3D here.
They were the ones who
brought in the system
and set it all up.
And in our
conversations, they've
mentioned things like, yes,
we have these big playback
systems that can do the 9.1
set up, or even larger set ups,
but also encoders that work in
stereo left and right for that.
So you don't have to go out
and retrofit your entire home
theater system to
be able to reap
the benefits of this technology.
So that's great.
We've seen game changers before.
The CD changed the
musical landscape.
And then we've also seen
failed game changers,
like who has a minidisc player?
I actually do have
a minidisc player.
OZARK HENRY: Yeah, me too.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It's a great technology,
but it didn't stick.
And you said you
were doing this.
We're working toward
the streaming element,
but right now it's Blu-ray.
What if it turns out that
Blu-ray doesn't stick?
OZARK HENRY: But I think
the Blu-ray doesn't.
Everything will become you can
stream it, you can download it.
I think the idea to put all your
effort in a carrier is weird.
It's like having a phone
with a bad receiver.
And the only effort you do is
to make it smaller and smaller
instead of working
on a better receiver.
I think the technology
is out there.
You can make this wonderful.
You have a great canvas
to make wonderful music.
And if the platforms make
it available, which is,
I think, just saying a yes
or a go, then there we are.
And then of course, you have the
choice to build up your system.
There's a lot of people
already having a 5.1 system.
When making this
album, of course,
we started-- because it was our
dream to have the 9.1 set up.
And then Ronald made
versions in 5.1 and stereo.
So you can downsize.
And of course, we also have
an MP3 version of this album.
So it's out there
in many formats.
The question is not what
could be the best carrier
to hold all those formats.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
That seems to be
a common thread across
many artistic media lately,
is getting away from the
sticking point of the medium,
and finding a way to get
back to the actual creation,
the actual experience.
RONALD PRENT: And up the
quality for the listener.
Bigger canvas.
OZARK HENRY: I think if
we would talk about wine,
we would never have
this discussion.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It wouldn't matter
what bottle it would come in.
You'd focus on the taste.
OZARK HENRY: No,
I mean if we would
downsize the quality that much.
I'm a wine lover, so for
me, this makes sense.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: You
touched on the home theater
applications, which, of
course, you think 5.1 surround,
you think home theater or
movie theater applications.
so that's film and now music,
and being able to present
it that way, but there's more.
You were talking about
maybe sports applications
in various ways.
And then your great
upcoming project as well.
OZARK HENRY: Yeah, well
I'm a goodwill ambassador
in the fight against
human trafficking.
And I want to make an
immersive sound experience that
can travel from music festival
to music festival that
gives people an
experience of like three
minutes, an experience
of how it feels
to have your identity taken
away and to have control
of your life taken away.
Why?
Because a lot of
people don't know what
human trafficking is about.
They don't know
what it stands for,
and therefore they don't
recognize when it happens.
That's also the case
mainly for victims.
They don't realize that they are
victims of human trafficking.
And if you realize that
human trafficking is
as lucrative as the whole
industry around drugs or arms,
then you know it's a
big thing in itself,
and it's something we have
to do something about it.
It shames us all, and
every country in the world
is affected by it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Even
just discussing it before,
the idea, the concept of being
inside of a shipping container
and being exposed to the
sound experiences in a three
dimensional way, it
gives me anxiety.
It makes me feel
uncomfortable even
thinking about the concept.
So I hope that you can find what
you need to fully realize that.
And I hope that in the
future we can find--
OZARK HENRY: Yeah, and I
hope it will have its effect,
and that people think about
it and realize that it's not
as invisible as we think.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Have you
done a lot of-- and maybe this
is actually a question
better for you in the studio
environment, a lot of
discussion with this technology
and with this
approach to recording
music with other artists?
And what sort of
feedback are you
getting from other musicians?
RONALD PRENT: We've done not
recording a project like Piet's
from the beginning,
but at the moment,
we also do a lot of
back catalog when
there's interesting material.
We did Tiesto "Elements
of Life" album.
That's 10 years old this year.
We did "Dead" in 9.1, which
is original dance music.
And it's amazing that stuff
that's done 10 years ago,
and you get only the
way they work in steps--
in groups of instruments.
Like you could still do
with immersive sound to make
a different experience
in the dance.
And I've just recently
done a project
with a guy called [? Press. ?]
He's a DJ out of London,
and that's EDM music.
And that's a brand new album
that comes out in two months.
And we've done a
9.1 version of it.
And it's for them, it's drugs.
I did three tracks for tryout.
He came.
He sat there.
He sat the whole day and
listened to these three tracks
and went out of his mind.
He said, this is possible?
I said, yes.
This is possible
with all your music.
And then the other eight tracks
that I had to mix got remixed.
He went back to London,
and I got new versions.
Because he knew
what was possible.
He went along, and
because for them it's
a permanent creative process
of creating and then mixing,
it's very close together.
And in 9.1, that's a bit
more difficult, that process
for him.
Because he cannot change
everything every 10 seconds.
But they do, and they come
up with great ideas what
to do with beats and how to use
the speakers in an arrangement.
To not put something in
the top, because it's
nice to put it there.
It's because it has a function
in music, and even in EDM.
I tell you, it's not what I play
at home, but it's great to mix.
It's really fun to be in,
because there's no limitations.
You have this big space, where
you can put all kinds of sounds
in and create a vibe
for five minutes.
And so you see that when you
bring artists into that process
early or even later, they start
rethinking their whole-- oh,
now I can do this.
Now I can do this.
Now I can have this excitement.
Now I can have this dark mood.
And it's much easier
for them to produce it,
because in stereo you have this
little, small window that you
have to look through, and have
to cramp everything in there,
and they want
everything in there.
So it sometimes
becomes a flat thing
that we then make loud so
everybody thinks it's exciting.
Whereas if you give
them this whole space,
it doesn't have to be loud.
Because it's loud because
of the space that there is.
So you don't need
all the processing
that we now in today's
world use to make everything
brutally loud so they
think we listen to it.
And it's really this small.
It's like his canvas.
It's a small window
that you look through.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: We're
going to leave some time
available for questions
and answers from you
guys in the audience.
We do have the mic set up
in the aisles for that.
But we did promise you
a listening experience.
So I think we'll bring up a
little bit of house lights,
because we want to encourage
you guys to be mobile.
Experience it in the
box, outside of the box.
Let some people change up sides.
But you guys brought
some listening samples.
So maybe you want to set that
up and explain the audio.
RONALD PRENT: Piet?
OZARK HENRY: I think
first we're going
to listen to a song called
"Love is Free to Interfere."
And they're going to
switch from stereo to 9.1.
So to give you an idea in
what way the dimension changes
and also the positioning of
where the instruments are
completely changes.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - OZARK HENRY, "LOVE IS
FREE TO INTERFERE"]
[END PLAYBACK]
OZARK HENRY: So as you can hear,
it's a different dimension.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It's
amazing how different it is.
I mean, even just
sitting here on stage,
the change between the 9.1
mixes and the stereo mixes
is so vast.
And we're technically
on the outside
of the box and the system, but--
RONALD PRENT: And again, if
you compared with a painting,
it's just looking at a
different angle of the painting.
Even if you're not
inside the circle,
and it's just a different
way of looking at the light.
OZARK HENRY: And as long
as you're in this space
and you move, it's like
going to a concert.
You're always in
that experience.
You're always in that
moment, and that's
what's so cool about it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Every
bit, turning the head,
turning your body,
it changes everything
about the experience.
It's very cool.
I think we have one
more good sample that we
can play in the full 9.1.
And then we'll move
on to questions.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - OZARK HENRY,
"GODSPEED"]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
OZARK HENRY: Cheers.
Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: That is
something unlike anything I've
ever experienced before.
So you definitely
nailed it there.
I think we do want to open
it up to audience questions.
If you guys have some
questions, please make your way
to a mic on either side.
And we have a few
minutes for that.
We would be remiss if
we didn't take a moment
to thank Nico from Auro-3D and
[INAUDIBLE], who came to set
all this wonderful stuff up.
So I think they're sticking
around a bit after.
So if you guys have
technical questions,
these guys might be
able to field that.
But why don't we
start over here?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yes, hi.
Thank you for the experience.
It was great.
I was wondering, was
there any thought
put into adding a layer
in the center speaker?
And if not, what was
the reason for that?
RONALD PRENT: Adding a what?
AUDIENCE: The front and
center speaker, there
was no layer added to that one.
I was wondering whether there
was any thought put in to that.
Was there any specific
reason for that or not?
RONALD PRENT: No,
it was intentional.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: There are
arrangements of the system
where you use a voice of God.
RONALD PRENT: There
is an arrangement
of the system in 10.1, where
there is a center top speaker.
But the music format
in Auro-3D is 9.1,
the way it's set up here.
So there is an 11.1 for cinema,
and there's a 13.1 also.
But for music, they
have chosen the 9.1,
because that is commonly
easiest to integrate into a home
system.
AUDIENCE: I see.
RONALD PRENT: At the moment.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Please, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think you might
have just answered my question,
but I was going to
ask how you chose
9.1 when it seems
like adding more
and more speakers in
an ever denser array
would just be even better.
RONALD PRENT: But
more speakers also
can give more problems in
timing between the speakers.
5.1 is an established
format, and the added four
high speakers or the 5 if you
use the center top speaker,
give you enough space to use
them as discrete sources.
So it's not mapped encoding like
there is Dolby or DTS, where
you have grids where
you map your speakers
in certain places.
But that gives timing issues.
This is a discrete
system in that sense,
and like I said,
easier to integrate
into the home than
more speakers.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: OK.
AUDIENCE: We were talking
about this earlier.
I've worked in a few sound
reinforcement situations, where
it's like an
auditorium like this,
but it's 10 times the size.
It hold two or three
thousand people.
And that configuration
was set up
with pockets of stereo
in different places
with various delays.
Is there too much
going on in 9.1
to do something like that in a
similar situation, where you'd
have pockets of
9.1 so that people
can experience in their
pocket of the auditorium?
Or does that take away
from the experience
like we were doing
earlier, where
we were walking around in it?
RONALD PRENT: That would
take away from that.
We haven't done any
experience like that.
In the past, we did it
for a group of 150 people.
And it's still a circle.
It's still containable.
If you go outside
that, for instance, we
were talking only about clubs.
What could we do there?
You have to then work
with PA-related systems,
where you have to
use the timing.
But if you do it with clusters,
in the experiments that we have
done with Meyer
Sound, it's still
you have to contain the
circle to have the experience.
If you start adding
extra 9.1 clusters of it,
then the experience goes away.
It becomes almost stereo.
But it is doable, but it's
not done on a big scale yet.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My technical
question was answered,
so I have a question
for Piet, actually.
So you mentioned before in
the beginning of your career
that you were struggling more.
And I'm also from
Belgium, so I guess
I know a little bit of
the back story and so on.
And it struck me that compared
to other Belgian artists,
you, even if you were struggling
in the first few albums,
you always were at the
same time building out
a more international career
than some of the others.
But more in the shadows,
whereas other Belgian bands,
they got write-ups in the press
about their American tour,
even if nobody showed up, but
they made a big deal out of it.
And now you're a UN ambassador.
And you've covered David
Bowie, and he tells you
what he thinks of it and so on.
Was that a deliberate
choice to stay away
from Belgium in
some sense, and work
on an international career?
Or is that just how--
OZARK HENRY: No,
not really, no, no.
I just go where I'm invited.
So it just took me by surprise.
Because as you know, there's
a French part of Belgium
and a Flemish part of Belgium.
I think you're probably
from the Flemish Part
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OZARK HENRY:
Because I was really
going good in the French
part starting out, and being
quite famous.
But that was the funny thing
about such a small country,
that apparently what happens on
the other side, nobody knows.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, nobody knows.
It's true.
Anyway, it's great to hear a
song like "Godspeed," that's
been around for so
long in this completely
different arrangement.
OZARK HENRY: Cheers.
Thank you.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about a maybe
competing audio technology.
I forget the name
of it, but it's
where you record from
the full 3D environment
with two microphones that are
the distance of the human ears.
And it creates the
same kind of 3d thing,
and then you have to play
it back through headphones.
Can you compare and contrast
that technology and this one?
And if you could remember
the name of that one,
that'd be really nice.
RONALD PRENT:
There were several.
But binaural--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's the on.
RONALD PRENT: Technology.
But it gives you the feel
that you're very isolated
in your headphones.
That's why some
people didn't like it
and other people like it.
This, you cannot
compare the two.
The experience is
completely different.
AUDIENCE: So in this one,
you can move around more
in the space, and it changes.
RONALD PRENT: Here, you can
move around in the space,
and it's like looking through
a picture at a different angle.
There in the center, you have
the most beautiful experience.
But if you're
sitting on the side,
you are looking at a different
angle of the same picture
and have a similar experience.
You hear the same things, but
you hear them differently.
But they still
relate to each other.
And in binaural in a
headphone is only you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It's
sort of a fixed point.
RONALD PRENT: It's
a fixed point, yeah.
And it's happens inside
your head, not around you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious
if there's any work being done
in live applications of this.
For example, in TV, they
do editing on the fly
all the time, switch from
one camera to another camera
and so forth.
I can almost imagine
having a live concert
with a group of sound
engineers who are also
part of the performers as
well, and they're actually
mixing and moving
different sounds
to different parts of the stage.
RONALD PRENT: We can
when we mix it in post.
We could do it.
I haven't done it yet.
It's not required.
I know they're working on
a broadcast application.
I'm imagining a
sports event in 9.1.
I've heard a sports
event in 9.1.
And it's made a picture.
It's amazing.
You might like football
all of a sudden.
And the same goes
for live concerts.
If you can do them
in 9.1, then it
is a totally
different experience.
5.1 is exciting, but
this is a different life.
But currently, there are not
applications available for that
at the moment.
AUDIENCE: I could just
see the [INAUDIBLE]
becoming a performer as well.
RONALD PRENT: Yeah,
you become part of it.
AUDIENCE: So you
used the analogy
that in stereo, you make
the music louder to make
it feel like you're present.
And with the more speakers,
it doesn't have to be as loud.
Well, this was plenty loud.
OZARK HENRY: Yeah, I mean
this is also a piece of music
where the orchestra
gets at the highest
and most dynamic points.
So that's what you feel.
If it would be in
a venue, you also
feel that it's almost too much.
So that's a very natural--
AUDIENCE: So what
I was wondering
was if you could comment on
the possibility of making music
that as present but not as loud.
Probably because many of
us are facing problems
with our hearing,
because we've been
listening to our headphones
on loud for a while.
OZARK HENRY: Yeah, and
also listening to music
in a very bad quality that
has no natural dynamic.
If you're listening
to music, the dynamic
is always at its height,
which is very unnatural.
If an object falls
on the ground,
like on a concrete floor, it
makes a very hard and loud
sound, but it's just an instant.
It's not constantly.
If you put your
little earphones in,
it's like that thing banging
the ground but for hours.
It's normal that you go deaf.
You will never have
this with the system.
The moment that it goes
loud, it's a dynamic.
It's an instant.
It's not all of the time.
It's a natural dynamic.
Natural dynamic doesn't
damage your ears.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It
speaks to a conversation.
OZARK HENRY: I think it's
true, what I'm saying.
Even like from a
medical point of view,
this is the way not to go deaf.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It's been a long time.
OZARK HENRY: Even if
you would put it louder,
but you don't have to,
because the quality at source
is also more interesting.
Music is louder because
we have a poor quality,
and we try to boost
what's not there.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It's
been an ongoing conversation
in the audio engineering
world for sure.
You get into conversation
about compression,
and how much you're just
squeezing everything in
to take up all the space
that you have available.
RONALD PRENT: The loudness war.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Yeah, it's basically
someone leaning on your ear
drum for 3 and 1/2 minute.
RONALD PRENT: Yeah, it
turns into big noise.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Then breathe, come back.
OZARK HENRY: Yeah, just putting
your finger straight in.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I've tinkered
with ambisonics in the past.
And I'm wondering how your
technology compares to that.
So with ambisonics, you
have your sound source
somewhere in a certain location.
And then you have an
immediate mathematical mapping
from the sound source
and the location
to the individual
signals for the speakers.
Now, the way you set up
your mics in the recording,
I don't think you have such
straight forward mappings.
So I'm wondering how this works.
RONALD PRENT: No, it is
basically just great mixing.
I've chosen for three different
sorts of microphoning.
And then I've sat
down on a console
and panned them
where I want them.
And it's all discrete
audio, so just
discrete channels, no mapping.
It's where I put when
I mix it, where we
decide we want to hear a sound.
That's where it goes.
That's where it stays
in the creative process.
And afterwards, it
doesn't get mapped.
Of course, it has to be encoded
to be played back from a disk,
but it's linear.
There's no software
involved that tells you
where the sound has to go.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I think we
have time for probably two more
questions.
So we'll take one more
here and one there.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I'd like to say thank you
very much for bringing
this beautiful, immersive
sound experience to us.
It's not easy to be able to
experience this, especially
the media as well.
A lot of the questions
here were answered with,
we chose 9.1 to add a
layer on top of 5.1,
because it's the most direct
for bringing to the home.
It's a sad truth,
however, a lot of homes
don't have proper
sound dampening, right?
Sound damping.
In that situation, is it more
difficult to listen to and damp
for a 9.1 system versus a 5.1?
And what are the effects
of no damping at all,
or poor damping?
Is it more exacerbated?
Or does the height
layer actually
help a less properly
damped system?
RONALD PRENT: In my
own home experience,
it actually helps to
have a bigger experience
where you have the speakers.
At home, you don't
necessarily need big speakers.
Auro does also demos
in a little cubicle
with nine little speakers.
And it works also, you could
do it with these speakers.
At home, even if it's
very reverb in your room,
with the top speakers, you
actually get a better picture
than with just 5.1.
It's my experience at home.
I did put a carpet on the floor
at the end to make it better,
but I have this little
speaker, and it works.
You don't need big
speakers to have
a powerful, immersive
experience, whereas sometimes
in the high end
systems, you end up
with bigger speakers to
have a good representation
of the music.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
RONALD PRENT: You're welcome.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
OK, last one.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming
here, and a simple question.
For ages, all the creators
have had this subconscious bias
where everything
they're creating
is for the front platforms only.
Now with technologies
and immersive
sound being created in a
way where you could place
a listener in the
center of the platform
instead of putting in front
of them or opposing them,
do you see the
creative processes
themselves changing or evolving
so that, say, the composer is
going to say, OK, for this one,
I'm going place my cello number
two and three in this
corner, and my triangles
at a little height or
something like that?
OZARK HENRY: I think if
it makes sense to the work
that you're writing, sure.
Sure, because you would do so.
The interesting thing is that
it becomes the same thing
as almost performing.
If you perform, you'll
also choose a certain set
up that is reacting to the room.
If the room has a
different sound,
then you will also place
the instruments sometimes
in a different way, because
some groups become too loud,
and you want to control
that, because it's not
amplified the way we play.
So it's exactly the same thing.
You have a space, and
within that space,
you want something to happen.
And the way you put
things in that space
is totally your choice,
and it's your freedom.
And that's what's
so interesting.
Because all of a sudden,
that frame is gone,
and you have a full
room to work in.
And it feels that
everybody who's listening
is also participating.
And the fact that
you realize that
makes you more ambitious
about what you're doing.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Do you find
yourself in a creative place
again now?
I mean, I know that you're out.
You're talking about
the record, talking
about sharing this
experience with people
of what you've made.
How much are the wheels
turning for the next thing?
OZARK HENRY: I'm writing.
I'm ready to go.
I've got way too much material,
which is always the case.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And for
the few people out there
who are waiting for maybe a
Word reunion for the next album
to come out and be
9.1 and hip hop?
Would you go back
to your beginnings?
OZARK HENRY: I don't know.
I don't know.
What I'm doing now is something
that I haven't done before.
Without saying much about it,
it has become more world music.
And I'm still looking
for people to help me out
on financing my 9.1
version, to be honest.
Doing all this is something
that I support myself.
I don't get any
support from a label.
I love it, but it's not like
a commercially great idea
to invest in for now.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, we thank
you very much for taking
the time to come and join us
at Google today.
OZARK HENRY: Cheers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It's an honor.
OZARK HENRY: Thank you.